mais mon sont à rentrer dans les
toilettes si on dépense 3 métiers s'est
fait taper les portes
qu'est ce que tu fais la barre que soit
fait là bas
et en russie
la formule 1 postale pour l'huile
si on maintient
pour cris d'effroi désert 6 a beaucoup
de boulot on venait à 7h30
voilà une personne et va rentrer dans
une tamoule
max membres vont dire qu'il faut que tu
désires c'est pendant 30 minutes ou de
cinq minutes comme ça
nous on travaille on travaille quand
elle s'impose contre avec 4 et s'impose
parce que nous on the n'y a pas de
projet il ya une seule personne connue
mais dans les contenus alors que c'est
bas normands il ya des trucs son nouveau
mois de décembre les frigos et les trucs
là qui vient d'être clos c'est
obligatoire que tu fais vite
pourtant les acquis sont en bois sont
ici et ils les refusent de faire les
déchargements mais nous on n'a pas le
choix nous avons fait tous parce qu'il
nous maltraitent comme des esclaves en
fait on travaille la nuit il ne paie pas
est retenue les airs si possible ces
impayés les r6 provision doit les faire
parce que nous les uns des chronos à
nous on n'est pas des papiers
une fois qu'on est fils de faire des
heures sup seulement ils vont ils vont
nous virer quoi donc ils sont embauchés
en intérim
via une cascade de sous traitance
puisque chronopost fait appel à la
société derichebourg qui elle-même fait
ensuite appel à une agence d'intérim
principalement l agence mission intérim
donc à une cascade de sous traitance ses
collègues sont employés à temps partiel
très souvent à 50% d'un temps complet
voire moins de 50% des trains complets
ce qui fait qu'ils sont payés moins de
la moitié d'un smic environ 600 euros
deux ou trois personnes qui travaillent
avec les miens papier avec tout ça ils
vont dire que l'on n'est pas au courant
il n'y avait pas des sans papiers
dallaire site
non je suis pas daccord désolé et
associé de chronopost connaît
parfaitement leur situation et en
profite puisque ses collègues là
contrairement aux autres salariés ne
bénéficient pas de pause
si jamais ils doivent s'arrêter pour
raison de maladie
eh bien ils ne sont pas réembauchés par
la suite donc ils connaissent une
situation de travail qui est vraiment
moyenâgeuse et ils n'ont pas accès au
minimum du droit dont bénéficie
l'ensemble des salariés en france
la maladie
on a une fois parler avec leur drh
yapobi loi une fois encore une partie
manifester l'avant comme quoi il a dit
que je ne suis pas employeur qu'elle les
ans les pronoms disent qu'ils n'avaient
pas de s'empêtrer dans leurs sites
nous on a nos preuves avec cette semaine
ils nous envoient une mission de la
semaine nous on a pris les photos de
l'intérieur de leur site
on a contra fils de p on a tous un
vêtement c'est pourquoi j'ai quitté
sommes allés pour aller en algérie
algérie maroc et j'ai traversé la mer d
les venir en espagne on est fluide et
quito au pays là bas on voit qu'ils
s'envoient pas du tout là bas
une fois arrivé ici on trouve dans la
même situation bizarre comme ça c'est
décevant
en fait
oui